today I'm going to be speaking with Dr
Mary Claire O'Brien who's a professor of
emergency medicine at Wake Forest
University School of Medicine who was
the leading medical expert in forming
the FDA decision to remove pre-mixed
alcoholic energy drinks from U.S markets
back in 2010. it's really great to have
you on today I appreciate it thank you
so much for inviting me so maybe to
start with energy drinks in general when
we talk about what they are I think most
people understand it's a stimulant of
sorts some of them have caffeine which
we're used to getting when we drink
coffee what exactly is it always
caffeine or are there other stimulant
elements in these energy drinks and how
does the dosage compare to a cup of
coffee for example so those are all very
good questions so uh from a physiologic
standpoint energy is calories that you
consume but all of us would understand
that really what energy drinks do is
deliver caffeine in one or various forms
either added as a chemical or in guarana
or yerba mate or other things where
they're additives that are essentially
just other forms of caffeine
brewed black coffee has about
uh 34 the average Homebrew black coffee
has about 100 milligrams of caffeine in
it and that's a good strong cup of Home
brewed black coffee and a cola that you
would buy over the counter has about 35
or 50 milligrams of caffeine in it
energy drinks are very variable in the
amount of caffeine that they contain
because of a quirk of an FDA situation
in which they are not regulated as
beverage by the Food and Drug
Administration
so you can't pick up a cola on a shelf a
12-ounce Cola that has more than 70
Parts 70 milligrams of caffeine in it
which is 200 parts per million but an
energy drink oddly enough is considered
a dietary supplement by the FDA and they
are not regulated
an energy drink may contain anywhere
from you know 100 to 150 to 200
milligrams of caffeine those little
bitty energy shots that people pick up
all the time have 200 milligrams of
caffeine so in two ounces cold one chug
you're drinking the equivalent of two
very strong cups of hot black coffee
that you would otherwise take your time
to sip and you get that jolt of caffeine
right away when we talk about the
feeling of I have coffee and I feel
awake and energized sometimes there's
the belief that you are getting
something but in it but what's happening
really is that the caffeine is blocking
the Sleep pressure that builds up if I
recall correctly from Michael pollan's
book it's the buildup of adenosine that
over time makes us feel tired so the
caffeine is sort of like the money it's
delaying fee feeling tired really right
that's what it does yes so caffeine
although we call it a stimulant is not a
stimulant what it does is it makes you
feel less sleepy right now for those of
us who are sleepy who want to be
stimulated the feeling of having
caffeine and waking up we all are pretty
familiar with and most of us drink some
caffeinated beverage in the morning
however it is in fact not stimulating
you it's blocking the chemical that's
naturally released in your body that
makes you feel sleepy so so caffeine
makes you feel less sleepy it does not
stimulate you unless of course you talk
about the way that it potentially could
stimulate let's say your heart rate or
your blood pressure when large
quantities are consumed or when normal
quantities are consumed or what would
generally be regarded as safe in
susceptible individuals people who might
be sensitive to the effects of the
caffeine so before we get on to the
energy drink Health stuff how should we
be thinking about what you just
described is it different than how
something like Adderall or amphetamines
work 100 yes caffeine basically makes
you a little it makes you less sleepy it
is not an addictive substance in the way
that we would think about perhaps
methamphetamine and I'm not sure that
for the average person the difference
between being less sleepy sleepy and
being mildly stimulated makes a whole
lot of practical difference okay it does
however have uh important implications
when we start talking about mixing
energy drinks with alcohol and the idea
that if you take an energy drink or hike
consume large amounts of caffeine with
alcohol that it will stimulate you and
the fact that you feel a little bit less
sleepy means that the other
Neuropsychiatric effects of alcohol and
motor effects of alcohol are likewise
reduced when they are not okay so before
we introduce the alcohol part what are
the risks of just extremely high doses
of caffeine you know I remember a story
of someone who owned a coffee shop and
for their cold brew they used to
concentrate and one day somebody forgot
that it's supposed to be watered down
and all of a sudden the caffeine dose in
a cup is 10x what it's supposed to be
whether it's a caffeine in coffee or an
energy drink what are the risks of too
much caffeine too quickly
so the answer to that question uh has to
be preceded by it depends on whom are
the effects okay so in healthy
individuals who are not otherwise
susceptible the FDA says we shouldn't
consume more than 400 milligrams of
caffeine so let's say four cups of
coffee less than that is generally
regarded as safe unless you have a
pre-existing condition which you might
not know about but anyway that's what's
generally for a healthy non-pregnant
non-nursing adult that's considered safe
over what period of time in one day in a
day okay
for pregnant or nursing individuals that
number is 200 milligrams so no more than
two cups of coffee and it's not saying
that that is a good idea but it's saying
we think that's generally regarded as
safe
in adolescence it's 100 milligrams so
that's a strong cup of coffee but most
of us aren't going to give our 12 year
olds a strong cup of coffee in the
morning before they go to school but
that's the number or the limit that's
sort of been set by the FDA and then for
uh children there is absolutely no safe
level whatsoever zero American Academy
of Pediatrics even though uh they state
that 30 to 50 percent of adolescents
drink energy drinks there is absolutely
no level of safety established in
children adolescents should not drink
energy drinks children should not drink
energy drinks heart stop
and when we talk about the negative
Health consequences that having more
than that 400 milligrams can have what
are they
so I think uh most of us who've had a
little bit too much caffeine or had it
too late at night have experienced
jitteriness insomnia nervousness
sometimes at higher doses ringing in the
ears it can cause stomach upset nausea
there are it can cause flushing it's
also curiously thought chronic levels of
caffeine ingestion are thought to
decrease calcium absorption so one of
the things you worry about is over time
adolescents women drinking high levels
of caffeine or steady levels of caffeine
will that predispose to osteoporosis so
it definitely interferes with calcium
metabolism and then in pregnant
individuals high and or heavy use of
caffeine habitually has been associated
with increased risk for miscarriage and
for having babies that are small for
gestational age at Birth now that's all
you know most of us have been familiar
uh with some of the side effects that we
would get but remember in susceptible
individuals there are people who can't
even drink a single cup of coffee and
how do you know that you don't know
until you get you know superventricular
tachycardia and now guess what you can
only have decaf right which is not no
calf but you know much less cap so when
we introduce the alcohol component and
this could be an energy drink that is
already alcohol plus the caffeine in the
package it can also be the infamous Red
Bull and vodka right I mean these are
also drinks that one can kind of mix on
their own what happens when you combine
the two
so the pre-mixed alcoholic energy drinks
which is the terminology that was used
pre-mixed alcoholic energy drinks and I
won't mention the brands because I don't
want to give them air time but they're
they are 100 off the market in the
United States right and that and that is
because uh it is a very clear that
um increasing that mixing caffeine in
alcohol those pre-packaged things which
was never permitted by the FDA was never
permitted it's just the industry got
away with it until the FDA called them
um that uh that it is associated with
increased amount of drinking heavy
drinking binge episodes
so have your drinking more frequent
heavy drinking and an increased risk of
serious alcohol-related consequences
like driving with an intoxicated driver
being sexually assaulted assaulting
someone else sexually and being hurt or
injured enough to need to seek medical
attention and what we believe is that
the alcohol or pardon me that the
caffeine masks some of the cues that you
might get that you had had too much to
drink that the caffeine masks that for
the alcohol so you're still drunk if
you've drunk enough alcohol to get to be
drunk but you perceive because of the
caffeine that you're not as drunk as you
think you are and what you are is been
well described as a wide awake drunk and
that's a dangerous thing because you
think you're okay and you are not so
when we read about people who go to the
ER after combining these types of
elements and from what I've read one in
ten of those ER visits leads to a
hospitalization what is it people are
showing up with with what what is it
that leads to them ending up at the ER
so what happens is they go to a drinking
situation where they intend to party
sometimes they preload with a
caffeinated beverage sometimes they
consume the caffeine while they're
consuming the alcohol two things happen
one is that the caffeine starts to wear
off before the alcohol does because
alcohol is metabolized at a steady state
it doesn't matter how much you drink if
you have five beers or ten beers you're
going to chip away or your liver will at
how much alcohol there is independent of
how much you drunk you only can
metabolize a certain amount of an hour
those of us who drink caffeine are aware
that if you have two cups of coffee at
eight o'clock by one o'clock in the
afternoon you're ready for another cup
of coffee and this is because of the
half-life processing of the caffeine
versus linear with alcohol that is 100
correct so there's two things that
happen one is that the that the caffeine
uh starts to wear off before the alcohol
wears off
the second thing what that permits you
to do is to stay awake longer so if you
drink 10 beers you're going to pass out
but if you've High loaded on a lot of
caffeine the same amount of alcohol
might not make you pass out you keep
drinking longer so when the caffeine
wears off folks come into the emergency
department basically comatose because
they've drunk far more alcohol than they
would otherwise have been able to
tolerate without passing out because
they have had the effect of the caffeine
keeping them helping them to stay awake
longer wow yeah you know anecdotally I
I've had experience with this not in the
situation you're describing but since I
was a kid I I would have a sort of like
vasovagal episodes where I would faint
and as an adult I had a situation where
before boarding a flight in Rome I had
an espresso with my girlfriend in the
waiting area because it's Rome right I
mean what do people do and then on the
plane they served free wine I never have
alcohol on airplanes but I said I get
it's a long flight we're watching a
movie I'll have it was one espresso and
one glass of wine I was very dehydrated
and I fainted on a plane and it became a
horrible thing I needed you know 30 days
of a heart monitor to make sure I was
okay it was just one of these episodes
but that seems to be another and and
that's also that same combination of how
these things operate right it is and and
what that would tell you that you as an
individual are susceptible right so even
though the FDA would say oh you could
have up to Four Strong cups of coffee
every day you know better because you've
had the experience of mixing one
espresso with one glass of alcohol and
your body does not tolerate it right how
do you know whether or not you're one of
the susceptible individuals you have to
have something bad happening yeah I
figured it out right yeah what are the
um for people who regularly consume
either significant amounts of energy
drinks with or without the the alcohol
combination but in either case what do
we know about long-term health effects
so that's a very very good question and
one of the things that is challenging in
the research is that human studies on
caffeine high levels of caffeine over
long periods of time are really limited
by two things the first is tremendous
variation in individual sensitivity to
caffeine and then in the way it the
amount in which caffeine the rate at
which caffeine is metabolized so you
metabolize caffeine a little bit
differently than I do and that's because
we're all individuals because I'm a
woman you're a man you may or may not
smoke cigarettes you may or may not be
taking medications that would affect
your caffeine metabolism and so
individuals even if you had 10
individuals sign up for a lab trial
going into it that confounds the study
and secondly we we worry long term about
the cardiovascular side effects in
particular and again about bone density
and and the ability to do the research
that would establish it is ethically
constrained for that reason particularly
so for women when they're concerned
about where there are concerns about
reproductive effects of long-term use of
caffeine
when we talk about studies that make
claims and this is more General I think
about coffee than it is about energy
drinks per se but I'm curious your
thoughts uh you know drinking two to
three cups of coffee a day is associated
with longer lifespan right this is a
common thing and it's sort of like with
eggs coffee is good and then it's bad
and then it's good and it depends how
you test it or who you ask or when you
know with anything food and drink
related it seems that part of the
difficulty is whenever you're adding or
taking something away you're always
replacing with something else and it can
be hard to know whether the effect is
from the removal of some or what is the
best science we currently have about
those types of claims about a couple of
cups of coffee and longevity
so what we do know is that healthy
non-pregnant non-nursing individuals can
include an energy drink or a strong cup
of coffee or two in their daily diet
with
um in moderation
so just like you would do anything else
in moderation for healthy non-pregnant
non-nursing individuals
caffeine in moderation is thought to be
generally regarded as safe
and that's what we know now that's
extraordinarily narrow language it is
generally regarded
this yeah uh did you know when when my
girlfriend uh when we were in the
process of starting a pregnancy
um she was told by by a doctor that some
of the assistive
medications that exist we don't
currently believe they increase the risk
of reproductive cancers which again when
I hear that I say it sounds like they
might it sounds like they might and so
we really don't know
uh we know that it's generally regarded
as safe okay that's what we know uh with
the exceptions for pregnancy for nursing
uh for adolescents and for individuals
who might be susceptible whoever they
are yeah okay wow which I guess I guess
the answer is we maybe would like to
know more than we actually do know right
now
true remember that the there are
constraints around science that would
establish what's safe part of it is the
individual metabolism absorption of
these substances and then part of it is
the constraints over long-term health
effects that are unknown and and and
that limit our ability to reproduce in
the laboratory what people commonly do
in real life right
um last thing I wanted to ask you about
do you think that so obviously with the
pre-mixed drinks they're off the shelf
it's a regulatory decision that that was
made when it comes to I mean you tell me
coffee of different kinds or energy
drinks that are just energy drinks do
you think there needs to be more
regulation or government involvement or
is it really just about educating people
and making people aware of the amounts
of these things that they're consuming
so you asked my opinion so I'm going to
give you an opinion yes and I and I
think it's poppycock that they are
regulated as dietary supplements uh
their Beverages and that was a decision
made in the mid-1990s the decision that
the FDA made about limiting the caffeine
in Cola beverages was made in 1959 and
the energy drinks really came onto the
market in the 1990s uh particular late
1980s early 1990s and in the mid 1990s
the FDA made a decision that said these
are dietary supplements they're they're
not Beverages and if they were regulated
in the same way as are the can of
Coca-Cola that you can buy in the
grocery store right next to them then
that would make more sense to me I think
it's poppycock and if they were
regulated in the same way as soda the
differences would be labeling or also
there would be limits that would be
placed yeah there would be limits so we
mentioned guarana and yerba mate those
are both natural sources of caffeine and
so they are listed as additives to
energy drinks they're more caffeine now
I did a little research to prepare for
speaking with you and looked at a couple
of things on the shelf and most of the
most of the beverages that I saw do list
the amount of caffeine that's in them
okay however there is not
um
I just think we would not you would not
uh give you know three or four cups of
coffee to your average 13 year old you
would not let a kid in high school think
that an energy drink could serve as a
sports drink when they're not you you
would and yet that's what goes on yeah
wow well we will see if that ever is
there an appetite to change that do you
think it doesn't seem like it or there
is oh okay there is and and letters have
been written by a couple of senators and
these this goes back a while though yeah
is there a current appetite no was there
a lot of appetite in the wake of the
research about the health effects of of
energy drinks and alcohol yes did that
did that stir the pot about the health
effects of energy drinks at all without
alcohol yes has that uh energy and
enthusiasm for making change continued
it has not over the last decade and I'm
not sure why that is understood um
understood we've been speaking with Dr
Mary Claire O'Brien professor of
emergency medicine at Wake Forest
University School of Medicine thank you
so much for your time appreciate your
insights you're welcome I am impressed
with your level of knowledge about the
science of the subject and you can call
me anytime thank you